nikkyatu this film is such a fascinating
blend of genres it's this really
interesting domestic story and it also
has these kind of folklore and horror
elements to it
what about that combination was
appealing to you and made you want to
try that mixture
um I
knew I didn't want to execute a domestic
story with a black woman protagonist in
the ways that we've become accustomed to
seeing the few of these stories that are
actually told in the mainstream and so I
think horror and folklore allows
um a truthfulness in a way that we
traditionally shy away from and perceive
as pedantic or preachy
um genre utilizes or gives you Tools in
Your Arsenal that are really fun and
sexy to play with as a filmmaker whether
it's the soundscape or it's a creature
but all of it all of it is very
expensive in terms of VFX whether it's
practical
effects or it's CGI and so you know we
knew what we were up against but I knew
that my North stars of like bong Juno
the host and Guillermo del Toro's the
shape of water in terms of the films I
was thinking about uh stylistically but
then you have like Usman semben's black
girl that is a straightforward drama so
just it feels very cross genre and the
filmmakers I admire navigate cross genre
elements in their work so I got
permission from these filmmakers to
create what felt like a cross genre
piece that was a little tricky to pin
down
Cinco from your point of view when you
read Nicky out to script for the first
time what did you find most interesting
and fascinating about it there's a lot
going on I think that's like you said
there was so much going on and and she
tied it together so well and and I
always say that you know when I read
something as I've continued to progress
on this journey as an actor
um I always go even if I'm not in it I'm
gonna watch it and that was the biggest
thing is that from from every character
that I felt on the screen that had such
a such a pivotal storyline and narrative
to tell the story for Aisha everyone
mattered and then the backdrop of
elements of of of I guess like lore that
I had never knew before mattered and it
popped off the screen so
for me or popped off the page so then
the opportunity to
find a way where I can inhabit it or
convince her that I was the person to
inhabit it became the journey is that
hard to do
um no she actually made it like I mean
nikiatu is very specific
um she knows what she wants and I think
that's why people love her work as a
filmmaker and as an artist and I think
the connection that in this story that I
felt I had to
Malik she knew would make sense and
would help the vision overall become
even more potent so I think because she
already had an idea in mind
we had a great language of
interpretation of of me kind of running
that race
and and knowing that it was a race
because up until you get the call saying
yes
um you know she she holds the cards
close to her chest and then you know a
lot of actors will be like when I got
the script and I was
reading it and I knew and it's like yeah
I knew I had to convince this woman to
hire me
he actually had to convince Anna little
did he know because chemistry casting
was a big part of this process so once
we locked in our lead I had to observe
with the three Maliks that I narrowed
down who did she have the most chemistry
with and so she confirmed my suspicions
based on my observations we had instant
chemistry I think you know it was one of
those things that was just she said it
shows
um we did and and it was convincing both
women that it made sense you know like
and and I mean I knew that like I knew
that going I was like okay and then I
knew and it was once where do you
remember when there was a the zoom
hadn't turned off
and I heard them talking about me and I
was like I remember that and I go there
I go I go hey uh you don't remember this
I was like ah I think I should be out of
this conversation so I hit leave you
don't remember that I don't remember
what were they saying all good things
honestly like I didn't I mean at least
it was it was like
brief deliberation it just started like
yeah so that was good no I think he was
you know and and I was like oh uh you
know what I think I should I should
leave y'all I got you I should get out
of this conversation a little peek
behind the curtain I could have I could
have honestly turned my screen off and
then listened to the whole Choice happen
but I was like that wouldn't that
wouldn't be uh the way to go on this one
right now you wanted to be an upstanding
young man one like Malik yes yes this
art imitating life you know and I could
always say I didn't know right but I did
right you know Nikia for you you and
nikkiato have
a great history together you've worked
together on several projects can you
take me through the Journey of this one
was it a roller coaster was it ever in
danger of totally falling apart how many
years has this been for you too
wow well what I'll say is this actually
was the first story she shared with me
of her own you know Niki is kind of a
brilliant filmmaker but she's also a
writer and she had all these great
original ideas and she told this to me
maybe in 20
team ish
um but um
to be fair you know there were other
films that we tried to take on in other
projects
um so really we really started maybe in
2019.
um and we were both being brought into
the labs and I really thought this would
be the best story of hers within her
catalog to really pick up and and move
forward with it felt more tangible than
all the rest
and I knew it was something as a friend
she was always going back to and I just
thought you know what let's just do this
like
go for it okay a couple last things
Nikia since you have a history with
nikkiato we're going to talk about her
in front of her right now
um is when I watched this movie I and I
told you this from the first moment I
said oh I'm in the hands of a very
confident director here what has it been
like for you as her filmmaking partner
to see this Evolution and to see what
she's been able to achieve in this and
what how did you want to support her
the most in this evolution
well for the first half of that question
I think for me it was just like it's
about time you know I've been working
with her for so long we've been trying
to find you know financiers and
supporters who could literally put their
money where their mouth is and so when
we finally got that opportunity
I knew she was ready I knew she could
pull it off
it was just we needed to do it we needed
people to step out of our way and just
let her do her thing
um and she delivered in space I mean I
can't even say she did better than I
thought because I knew she could do it I
knew what she was capable of
and then
I can't really remember what the second
half of the question was but how you
wanted to support oh you know I try to
show up and support in a myriad of ways
I think as a her producing partner I
think the one thing I try to do is be a
chameleon because you know this was
still this was an independently funded
film the resources were stretched I
tried to make sure everything could go
to what you saw on the screen as much as
possible
so as her partner I try to be whatever
any department needs of me at any given
time so we can all cross that Finish
Line together and then I want to ask one
question to kyatu about the very
specific moment where
uh Aisha asks Malik to guess what
country she's from and she says it
starts with an S and he guesses Sierra
Leone and South Africa before he gets to
Senegal your Sierra Leone an American
was that put in there as a little shout
out to your home country of course I
always have to slide in a shout out
nobody knows anything about Sierra Leone
so and it's a tiny country and you know
as a Sierra leonean American filmmaker
other Sierra leoneans are like well why
isn't she Sierra Leone because they
don't understand the industry so they're
like why didn't you cast why didn't you
make this a Sierra leonean story and
it's much more complicated than that you
know but
um any even in the soundscape sampha it
was one of the artists he's an amazing
musician who's British Sierra leonean we
had the Condi band that's Sierra leonean
so I I snuck in hints that I am Sierra
leonean uh where I could I don't know a
few people are catching it here and
there but I had to I had to give a
little shout out to my people I
congratulate all three of you I love
this movie it's a pleasure to see all of
you great great questions
thank you for sticking around